according to police data from mobile
phone masts is crucial it puts the main
suspect near the mccann apartment an
hour or so before madeleine vanished
it's part of the circumstantial evidence
against christian bee the german drifter
suspected of abducting the little girl
according to her parents madeleine went
missing from her bed between 9 and 10 pm
but the suspect insists that by 10 p.m
he was many miles away along the coast
with a young german woman
he says they were having sex in his
campervan parked close to her family's
holiday villa
the suspect's alibi claim was news to
the german prosecutor who believes
christian bee is guilty
of the language
the suspect a convicted sex offender
claims the next day he drove the woman
to the airport to catch a flight home to
germany
on the way they were stopped at a
roadblock and questioned by police he
says officers took their photograph then
let them continue
but at faro airport the woman missed her
flight because she was arrested
according to the suspect she was stopped
at security when a scanner revealed she
was carrying a pepper spray a criminal
offense
even if the woman confirms a
relationship with christian bee it may
be difficult to prove they were together
at the crucial time
and if they were stopped the next day by
police unless the officers found
something suspicious it's doubtful they
kept a record of it and highly unlikely
they took photographs
there would be a record if the woman was
arrested but that alone would hardly
provide the suspect with an alibi
i wouldn't say that i'm surprised
christian b's former portuguese lawyer
said his alleged alibi shouldn't simply
be dismissed
if he does have that
that
alibi so he should really work on that
what i know from him it's
he was a straight person
he was a straight person
so if he says that that is
that is possible
two weeks ago christian b was made a
formal suspect by portuguese
investigators but has yet to be
interrogated by german prosecutors
they say their investigation may last
another year
martin brunt sky news portugal